ich begrüße dr alexander gauland
mitglied des bundestags und afd
bundessprecher sowie kontakte
vorsitzender der fdp fraktion im
thüringer landtag es geht um die
auswirkungen der landtagswahlen in
thüringen auf die bundespolitik und wir
haben etwa 15 minuten zeit für ein
statement vom podium und dann
entsprechend raum für fragen erhalten
bitte den anfang machen gut machen wir
das so ja zunächst zu sagen
die alternative für deutschland hat nach
sachsen und brandenburg nun auch in
thüringen vollen erfolg erzielt wir
hatten uns für diesen herbst großes
vorgenommen
und wenn man sich das anschaut dann
haben wir in brandenburg eine
verdoppelung in sachsen fast eine
verdreifachung und nun in thüringen
wiederum mehr als eine verdoppelung das
heißt wir sind eindeutig der große sagt
wahlsieger des gestrigen abends in
thüringen wie auch der landtagswahlen im
osten im ganzen
wir haben uns in allen drei ländern
hervorragend aufgestellt es bestätigt
sich was ich immer wieder sage was sie
an diesem platz auch schon ein paar mal
gesagt habe wir erleben eine zeitenwende
wir haben ehemalige volksparteien im
niedergang ich habe das hier schon
mehrfach gesagt das war auch gestern
wieder zu spüren und andere parteien
steigen auf sie hatten gestern noch cdu
und spd zusammen bei ziemlich präzise
30% wohlgemerkt zusammen dass es
bemerkenswert und ist es so dass im
links sozialistischen lager
üblicherweise die grünen vom niedergang
der spd profitieren hier was nun die
linke das ist ein thüringisches
spezifikum im bürgerlichen lager ist der
niedergang der cdu eigentlich eine
kommunizieren röhre zu unserem aufgang
wenn die cdu um elf prozentpunkte steigt
sinkt dann steigen wir um elf
prozentpunkte
das haben wir gestern wieder erlebt was
mich gefreut hat ganz persönlich muss
ich ihnen sagen weil ich die politik der
grünen sehr skeptisch sehe ist dass auch
bei dieser dritten landtagswahl im osten
die grünen jetzt sehr sehr schlecht
abgeschnitten haben
es scheint dass der hype der um die
grünen gemacht werden
am ende zugeht und es würde sie wundern
wenn ich nicht sagte das freut uns ein
weiteres schönes ergebnis sehr schönes
und wichtiges ergebnis es gibt keine
mehrheit für rot rot grün nicht in
thüringen nicht in deutschland
das heißt das bürgerliche lager
insgesamt den man uns ja einige
wohnzimmer nicht zu rechnen erreger
weise steht aber solider bei über 50
prozent das ist das ist ausgezeichnet
das ist eigentlich die punkte die ich
machen wollte und mehr habe ich auch gar
nicht
ich würde erstmal an herrn ag abgeben
als den spitzenkandidaten ich bin dann
der letzte wenn ich da jetzt hat mir wir
auch morgen schon vieles vorweggenommen
auf form einer seite herzlich willkommen
schön dass sie so zahlreich erschienen
sind einige schon gestern im thüringer
landtag gesehen einleiten möchte ich mal
anmerken dass nicht überrascht dass die
medien vor allen dingen vom wahlsieger
bodo ramelow geschrieben haben dass da
jedenfalls überwiegend die überschrift
der meisten medien ja die linke hat zwar
drei prozent dazu gewonnen aber es gibt
eigentlich noch einen sehr deutlichen
wahlsieger das ist die afd
jörg nolte hat schon gesagt wird über
100 prozent steigerungen eine leistung
die es noch niemals in der thüringer
landesgeschichte gegeben hat das hat
noch keine partei die im landtag schon
ist jemals geschafft und das zeigt dass
wir tatsächlich eine historische
leistung verbracht haben auf die ich
sehr stolz bin
viele thüringer bürger haben sie auch
nicht von der erlauben sie mir diese
bemerkungen sehr verehrte
pressevertreter sehr einseitige
medienberichterstattung vorfeld der wahl
beeindrucken lassen ich möchte in dem
zusammenhang fast schon von manipulation
reden das wird immer weniger
wirkungsvoll und das ist eine tendenz
die gut ist
sie kennen meine position dazu ich
begrüße dass grundsätzlich sehr was von
meiner seite unbedingt noch ergänzt
werden muss ist dass wir nach ersten
analysen außer die alterskohorten 60
alle alterskohorten gewonnen haben alle
vier alterskohorten unterhalb der 60
orte sind von uns gewonnen worden
man kann also sagen dass die regierungen
ramelow von den rentnern gerettet worden
ist und ich glaube das sagt doch schon
sehr viele ausländer das wählerklientel
der partei die linke in thüringen und im
osten
allgemein zum höhenflug der grünen
hatten schon richtig ausgeführt wir
haben in thüringen eine ein land das ja
gottseidank bevölkert ist von menschen
die diese den grünen sehr schwer machen
thüringen ist praktisch dass das wie
soll ich sagen das gegenteil von von
berlin muss ich vielleicht nur so
ausführen was die was die wo was den
wohlfühlfaktor der grünen angeht auch
das ist eigentlich eine schöne
ausgangslage
die spd ist keine volkspartei mehr nach
den drei ost wahlen das ist klar eine
partei die dreimal einstellig wird ist
leider als volkspartei geschichte
die cdu ist noch eine volkspartei aber
eine alte vergehe volkspartei
wir haben als fdp jetzt in diesen drei
ost wahlkämpfen mit durchschnittlich 25
prozent abgeschnitten
wir haben wie schon aus führte fast alle
alterskohorten gewonnen wir sind die
junge vitale volkspartei des ostens und
davon bin ich überzeugt dass wir
gemeinsam in den nächsten jahren diese
afg zu einer jungen vitalen volkspartei
gesamtdeutschlands entwickeln werden und
wir werden weiterhin unseren beitrag
dazu leisten was abschließend von -
bemerken ist ist auch dass es uns
gelungen ist als afd
die meisten nichtwähler zurück zur
wahlurne zu bekommen mehr als die
anderen parteien glaube ich sogar
zusammengenommen einen effekt den wir
schon nach der sachsen war nach der wahl
in brandenburg zu verzeichnen hatten das
macht uns stolz endlich gibt es wieder
etwas zu wählen und das tut der
demokratie gut und deswegen ist die haft
die wichtig für diese demokratie so
vielen dank erstmal von meiner seite
haben dass nämlich noch eine bemerkung
über die cdu machen wenn sie sich das
wahlergebnis anschauen dann gibt es in
thüringen eine bürgerliche mehrheit cdu
fdp
und afd aber ich habe das schon
mitbekommen die cdu geht einen anderen
weg
herr mohring hat jetzt von frau kam
karrenbauer bieten dass er mit herrn
ramelow gespräche führen kann
da kann man nur sagen es ist eine gute
idee damit die cdu endgültig untergeht
denn die ersten stellungnahmen gibt es
ja schon von carsten linnemann der
gesagt hat sie wird als volkspartei auf
zu bestehen wenn sie diesen weg geht und
ich bin mal sehr interessant wenn es
eine solche regierung in thüringen gibt
finde ich sehr interessant was dann cdu
mitglieder in baden württemberg oder gar
die csu in bayern oder in nordrhein
westfalen sagen
also ich glaube der weg für die cdu
führt ins nirwana und es wäre wichtig
die bürgerliche mehrheit die die wähler
gewollt haben umzusetzen
aber das ist aufgabe der basis der cdu
die sich gegen eine solche politik
natürlich werden muss mehr will ich
jetzt natürlich sein
dann beginnen wir mit fragen hiervon
bitte herr kollege wenn sie sich kurz
vorstellen
im frühjahr kein bild zeitung herr
goller sie haben gestern gesagt das hat
mich überrascht dass die behälter in der
mitte der partei sehen dann würde mich
interessieren wer es aus ihrer sicht
eigentlich rechts und von herrn oetker
was macht sie mit ich also ich wusste
dass das die erste frage ist es mir
heute prüfung gestellt worden
ich habe keineswegs die gesäß geografie
der französischen nationalversammlung
gemeinden zwischen links rechts und mit
jetzt interessiert mich nämlich auch
nicht sondern ich habe klar gesagt dass
von heute mitten in der afg steht und so
ist mit ja auch zu verstehen
mehr kann ich dazu auch nichts sagen drk
und hat das wunderbar erklärt dem ist
nichts hinzuzufügen
herr jung bitte land darf laut
gerichtsurteil
als faschist bezeichnet werden gilt als
rechtsextremer das heißt in der mitte
der partei steht und ist ein faschist
helgoland habe ich sie richtig
verstanden
sie wissen dass es unsinn ist sie wissen
dass bei uns die meinungsfreiheit in
manchen dingen für mich zu weit geht ich
würde jetzt zum beispiel nicht
wiederholen was auch die frühere
bundesministerin und grünen abgeordnete
genannt werden darf ich will dass gerade
weglassen
also diese art von zuschreibungen wollen
wir gar nicht erst aufrufen
denn natürlich ist die meinungsfreiheit
leider etwas was manchmal in einer weise
präsent in einer weise repräsentiert
wird die ich persönlich für falsch halte
auch wenn es um eine grüne wie frau
künast und von daher ist es natürlich
völlig auch unsinn dass herr höcker ein
faschist ist und von daher muss ich mich
mit dem team nicht weiter auseinander
setzt ich habe auch manchmal das gefühl
dass die menschen nicht mehr wissen was
faschismus ist
ich habe als kind noch ali wie mein
vater von der gestapo vernommen wurde
weil er mit einigen offizieren
befreundet war
die im ersten weltkrieg waren und dann
im umkreis des zwanzigsten juli standen
und kurz nach 45 ist mein vater dann von
der gpu verhört worden
ich hab das dumme gefühl die leute die
so reden wissen nicht mehr was
faschismus ist und deswegen halte ich
überhaupt nichts davon
solche zuschreibungen auf nutzer
diskutieren
das gericht das gericht wertet die
zuschreibung jahr auf basis einer
überprüfbaren tatsachengrundlage dass
herr höcker ein faschist ist helgoland
das stört sie offenbar nicht der mann
hat unternehmens anonym landolf lade ich
ns verherrlichende texte laut
verfassungsschutz und auch ihren
bundesvorstand veröffentlicht das kann
ja
ernst merkel werden sie eigentlich gegen
dieses urteil das sie faschist genannt
werden dürfen vorgehen oder ist das
ausdruck eines funktionierenden
rechtsstaates
ich denke herr dr gauland hat dazu
eigentlich ausgeführt viel ist da nicht
zu ergänzen
wir haben das problem dass er
mittlerweile in einer zeit leben in der
sogar angeblich gebildete menschen also
die dem inhaber eines akademischen
abschlüsse sind nicht mehr über das
minimum historischer bildung verfügen
wir haben zwei dahin weiterhin das
problem dass die begriffe nicht mehr
trennscharf gebraucht werden sondern
inflationär als kampfbegriff in die
politische arena geworfen werden um
kurzfristige erfolge zu generieren
heutzutage ist ist jeder ein nazi der
sagt denn ich sagt deutschland verrecke
so kann man das schon fast auf den
nenner bringen das heißt diese begriffe
sind entwertet worden sind nicht mehr
trennscharf und können wahrscheinlich
von den meisten gar nicht definiert
werden sollen ob sie den ob sie den
begriff faschismus überhaupt innerlich
erklären könnten jetzt mal fünf minuten
über den probe möchte ich gar nicht
machen also das ist der zustand der per
sprache leider muss ich sie ob sie das
urteil anfechten werden wir reden jetzt
über die trümmer landtagswahl nicht wahr
haben sie sich denn sonst wahrscheinlich
ist das gericht so wie wenn sie dagegen
vorgehen das war die frage ja zu dem
komplex ich mich würde interessieren der
gauland oder haben wollten ob sie das
buch von herrn röcke nie zweimal in
denselben fluss gelesen haben in
auszügen ich ja noch ist veröffentlicht
wurde
dann würde mich mal interessieren herr
gespräch von unseren bevor ständig
zitiere volkstod durch den
bevölkerungsaustausch es werde ein groß
angelegtes replikations projekt
notwendig seien und bei dem werde man so
fürchte er nicht um eine politik der
wohltemperierten grausamkeit herumkommen
und wenn einmal die wende zeit gekommen
sei dann machen wir deutschen mit keine
halben sachen teilen sie inhaltlich
diesel setzte ich weiß nicht ich habe
die sätze gelesen ich kann nicht viel
dass das etwas ist was man nicht
schreiben darf ich meiner ansicht nach
ist das buch auch in keiner weise auf
dem index von daher was soll die frage
ich bin nicht mit allen positionen
einverstanden
ich bin vor allem was er gesagt einfach
stein ots nicht mit allem was ich sage
einverstanden aber wir sind in den grund
ziehen der partei natürlich völlig einer
meinung und da interessiert mich jetzt
ein buch nicht sie können auch in
büchern von mir selbst zu finden die
nicht gefallen
das ist aber hier nicht zu diskutieren
können sie vielleicht dazu zusatz können
sie vielleicht von genannten zitaten
sagen welche sich inhaltlich teilen und
welche wichtig man das buch ich denke
gar nicht daran einzelne zitate die sie
herausgreifen in irgendeiner weise jetzt
zu kommentieren und mit sensoren zu
versehen
das ist ein buch das ist ein gesamtwerk
und da kann man unterschiedlicher
meinung sein und man kann bei bestimmten
zitaten sagen das könnte man auch anders
ausdrücken völlig richtig aber das ist
hier nicht sozusagen literaturkritik und
von daher werde ich mich auch
literaturkritik nicht beteiligen
und da sie mich auch ansprachen
man muss mit dem nicht mit jedem duktus
einverstanden sein aber das hier massive
veränderungen in der
bevölkerungsstruktur haben und dass sie
nicht zum vorteil dieses landes sind das
wird man nur noch ganz tatsachen
orientiert feststellen können schauen
sie wir haben einen netto abwanderung
von 100 also eine abwanderung brutto ab
wann von 140.000 jungen gut
ausgebildeten menschen pro jahr 60.000
kommen zurück bleibt netto abschluss von
von 80.000 menschen die überwiegend hier
groß
geworden sind die indigene deutsche sind
die hier erstellten kindergarten eine
schule in der ausbildung oder eine
universität durchlaufen haben die
verlassenen dieses land an
das heißt wir haben eine ganz klare
produktivitäts abwanderung zugleich
haben wir eine massive unbestreitbare
sozial migration in dieses land hinein
wie immer man das nun in der
formulierung nennen will aber hier
passieren tatsächlich demokratische
veränderungen in der
bevölkerungsstruktur die unserem lande
ich verdrückt mal höflich aus nicht
dienlich sind
und das ist eine bewusst zurückhaltend
gewählte formulierung wenn sie sich kurz
vorstellen
sabine am orde von der tat vermuten ich
wüsste gerne ob sie die einschätzung von
herrn bauland teilen das herrliche in
der mitte der partei stehe und diese
nicht nach rechts rücke hätte mich auch
überrascht finde ich das nicht auch
sowie sowie helgoland das erklärt hat
und er ist kein freund des des alten
links rechts kontinuums kann ich kann
ich das nachvollziehen ich würde
eigentliche position von herrn hüppe
wenn ich sie in das recht links rechts
continum einordnen müsste nicht als
mittig klassifizieren
das ist auch bekannt andere würde ich
eher als links einordnen
vielleicht könnte man straßenfahrer
sagen gesellschaftspolitisch deutlich
rechts wirtschafts und sozialpolitisch
deutlich links ist im durchschnitt damit
ich ja so könnte man das etwas etwas
ironisch formulieren ich würde ansonsten
dieser hat diese einschätzung so wenn
sie den satz isolierten eben nicht
teilen das wundert sich aber auch nicht
auferlegen bitte ich fand das auch nicht
es tut mir leid ich fand das jetzt auch
nicht so verständlich sie haben zwar
gesagt was sie nicht mal nämlich dass
rechts links schema mit dieser äußerung
aber was sie sonst da als als mit ich
empfinden habe ich auch nicht verstanden
meinen sie das
auch von allen gleichermaßen geschätzt
und wird da es würde mich ein bisschen
wunder weil es gab ja auch da so
unterschriftenaktionen die sich also
klingt seine strömungen der partei
richteten also vielleicht erklären sie
es noch mal für alle also ich weiß nicht
ob man durch zwei mal erklären eine
sache besser versteht er steht mitten in
der partei das habe ich gesagt das habe
ich aus gedrückt und dabei ist mir
völlig egal ob er jetzt mitten in der
partei etwas linker steht heute zu recht
auf die sozialpolitik gewiesen oder
mitten in der partei bei der
identitätsfrage und historischen fragen
etwas rechter das wirklich meine aussage
sondern er steht mitten in der partei
und wenn jemand als spitzenkandidat von
thüringen knapp 25 prozent der wähler
hinter sich vereinigt dann ist er
bestimmt keine randfigur und genau das
und nur das habe ich ausgedrückt zusatz
dh also jeder der nicht eine randfigur
es weil er zb von einem
parteiausschlussverfahren bedroht ist
steht in der mitte der partei in dieser
logik
nein natürlich nicht und röcke ist nicht
von einem ausschlussverfahren der partei
bedroht aber natürlich würde ich von
herrn gideon oder frau sayn wittgenstein
das in keiner weise sagen
wie käme ich dazu und es ist auch völlig
richtig dass herr paczensky gestern in
der sendung bei anne will an einer
stelle gesagt hat naja von manchen
möchte ich mich trennen das sind die
namen die ich genannt habe das hat mit
hermann gabel überhaupt nichts zu tun
herr kollege bitte herr kollege sie
hatten sie auch gemeldeten eine frage im
grunde alle sie haben es schon
angesprochen kurz vorstellen bild.de
haben
selbst gesagt dass sie vor allem aus dem
lager der nichtwähler stimmen gewonnen
haben anders als bei den wahlen in den
westlichen bundesländern so sehr vor
allem von der cdu gewonnen haben was in
dem fall so dass wirklich vor allem die
nicht wähler fw gewählt haben was
glauben sie woran das liegt ich kann
ihnen sagen woran das liegt an einer
regulativen analyse ist jetzt noch nicht
erfolgt dazu waren noch nicht die zeit
erstens wie ich das eingangs schon sagte
es gibt da endlich mal eine partei die
sich vom altparteien einerlei
unterscheidet sehen sie das ist das
wichtigste sieg meiner staaten
parteiendemokratie wie sie richard von
weizsäcker anfang der 90er jahre schon
definiert hat dass die parteien sich
inhaltlich immer mehr annähern gucken
sich auf die großen politikfelder der
euro rettungspolitik der energiewende
politik oder der einwanderungspolitik
von nsn abgesehen sprechen die heilt
parteien von der linken bis zur cdu mehr
oder weniger mit einer stimme und auf
einmal ist da eine partei die genau
diesen drei zentralen politikfeldern in
denen sich die zukunft dieses landes
entscheidet meiner festen überzeugung
nach tatsächlich alternative position
ausgebildet hat und jetzt auf einmal das
demokratische angebot wieder verbreitert
das ist eine wesentliche ursache es gibt
wieder etwas zu wählen mit der
alternative für deutschland so jetzt hab
ich den faden verloren
das zweite ist meiner meinung nach dass
wir weil wir auch von ihnen das ist
jetzt kein pauschalurteil über es gibt
auch viele rhätische journalisten bei
den etablierten medien weil wir von
ihnen so ein bisschen na ja falsch
bezeichnet werden ist zurück ich mich
mal ganz diplomatisch aus gibt es ganz
viel solidarität solidarisierungseffekt
in der bevölkerung gerade bei den
nichtwählern die mit den altparteien
schon abgeschlossen haben weil sie die
phraseologie die leider von vielen
gepflegt wird nicht mehr ertragen können
wir müssen wieder wahrhaftiger werden
als politiker die menschen wünschen sich
politiker auch mit ecken und kanten die
ihn nicht nur nach dem munde
sondern die auch für klare positionen
stehen und ich glaube das honorieren die
menschen diese authentizität die gerade
von fdp-politikern personifiziert sind
und weil sie mich jetzt schon indirekt
oder direkt immer mal wieder jetzt
angegriffen haben in dieser
veranstaltung hier ja natürlich habe ich
auch fehler gemacht in meinem auftreten
ich war 15 jahre lehrer waren einen
bürgerlichen beruf und habe dass
politiker dasein niemals gelernt und bin
auch froh dass ich das nicht gemacht
habe dass ich keine klassische
parteikarriere gemacht habe die mich
abgeschliffen hätte aber ich glaube die
menschen verzeihen wir das auch weil sie
spüren dass ich das ernst meint was ich
will und was ich sage und dass das ist
ja etwas was was eher wieder positiv
gesehen mit und von daher davon gibt es
einige in unserer partei die ecken und
kanten haben wir das tut tut den
menschen gut und die menschen freuen
sich dass wieder offen und kann in der
politik und erneuten baden auch gefragt
so oder so ist eine freundliche
geschichte das kann eigentlich nur jeden
freuen die wahl mit 122 auf 66
geschrieben ob man es nun glühend
ablehnt oder vehement befürwortet die
menschen sehen dass sie etwas zu melden
haben gegen eine deutlich höhere zahl zu
erwarten wie auch immer man das war ein
ergebnis bewertet das ist positiv zu
bewerten
martin schmitt vermeide fernsehen
roland berger hat jetzt ein sehr gutes
ergebnis eingefahren sie sagen ja steht
in der mitte der partei würden sie sich
eigentlich wünschen er würde mehr
verantwortung in der partei übernehmen
stehen jetzt auch buch oralen an das
entscheidet der parteitag und werke
entscheidet darüber für welche position
er kandidiert das habe ich nicht zu
kommentieren und nicht zu bewerten
im übrigen aus meiner früheren cdu
mitgliedschaft weiß ich dass
landesverbände die einen großen wahlsieg
eingefahren haben das gilt aber jetzt
nicht nur vermögen das gilt auch für
sachsen und brandenburg natürlich im
vorstand gewisse ansprüche stellen das
ist in jeder partei so und ist keine
afg spezialität von daher könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass die ostdeutschen
landesverbände sagen wir wollen noch
stärker repräsentiert sein das ist ganz
normal
eine zusatzfrage in den nacken
sie hatten das ja auch schon mal relativ
unauffällig angekündigt dass sie sich
nach der wahl jetzt leidenschaftlich dem
bundesvorstand widmen wollen was
bedeutet das jetzt was kommt da jetzt
auch die partei zu
ja ich muss mich korrigieren morgen will
ich erstmal die fraktion gründen den
erfolg danach werde ich mich dann mit
leidenschaft im bundesvorstand
beziehungsweise der vorbereitung der
wahlen widmen
nein was was kommt auf die partei zu das
hat er schon wieder so eine einfärbung
diese frage der drk hat das richtig
ausgeführt ja wahlsieger wollen wollen
natürlich auch repräsentiert werden in
den wichtigen gremien der partei das ist
normal und ich denke wir haben einen
anspruch als osten deutlich
repräsentiert zu werden ja ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass der wahlerfolg
im osten und dass die volkspartei
wertung im osten auch was mit unserem
ansatz des solidarischen patriotismus zu
tun hat und ich glaube auch dass diese
solidarische patriotismus das
erfolgsmodell für die gesamtpartei sein
kann und sein sollte wenn wir den
nächsten jahren dann eine gesamtdeutsche
volkspartei werden wollen und das wollen
wir ja und von daher wünsche ich mir
natürlich auch im bundesvorstand
repräsentanten unserer partei die diesen
diesen ansatz auch wirklich
repräsentieren können ja und und dafür
stehen authentisch dafür stehen habe ich
eine wortmeldung gesehen rund um dieses
mikrofon
das ist offensichtlich nicht der fall
ja das war aber nicht rund um dieses
mikrofon dankeschön
ich hatte aber sie glaube ich gesehen
bitte an
1 davor es ist so kreutz ist jan
sternberg redaktions netzwerk
deutschland er hatte gerade gesagt er
solidarisch patriotismus werden nennt
wäre ein erfolgsmodell für die
gesamtpartei wie sehen sie das
ist das und zum bundesvorstand auf
einmal die frage sie frage ich jetzt
nicht ob sie kandidieren herren dann
frage ich auch nicht ob er kann den
preis dass er ist wieder offen gelassen
wird am morgen würden sie sich freuen
wenn herr kandidiert und für welche
position
und noch eine frage an herrn hüppe sie
hatten dem gesagt sie haben auch fehler
gemacht ihre politische karriere könnten
sie welche nennen und ich habe vorhin
gesehen als der kollege über golf war
ich sprach das hat hier nicht nur er
aufgebracht sondern auch frau lengsfeld
im wald wäre nicht ist hier ein guter
zeitpunkt klar zu sagen dass sie nicht
landolf leidig waren und nicht diese
artikel verfasst haben gut dann mache
ich mal den anfang
schauen sie wenn sie den begriff
solidarischer patriotismus nehmen dann
ist das auch erst mal wieder ein etikett
das ist ein etikett wie er sagen die eu
liberalismus oder sonst was man muss
schauen was was sich dahinter verbirgt
sich mit großer freund von pragmatismus
ich stehe auf der position der sozialen
marktwirtschaft das ist von mir bekannt
sofern das was helfe und andere unter
solidarischen patriotismus verstehen auf
der basis der sozialen marktwirtschaft
basieren sollte sehe ich da überhaupt
keinen dissens grundsätzlich ist mir
bekannt dass ich da sehr freiheitlichen
ansatz pflege und ich glaube es ist
sicherlich zu treffen und die anlage
würde dem nicht widersprechen dass wir
in teilen da unterschiedliche ansätze
haben
das ist aber normal wir sind eine partei
die nicht eine kleine klientel partei
ist sondern wir stellen uns gerade als
volkspartei auf und wenn sie die die
wahl erfolge sehen kann man doch nicht
in abrede stellen dass wir darin sehr
weit fortgeschritten sind wenn das so
ist dann müssen wir logischerweise ein
gewisses spektrum haben und dass man
dann innerparteilich
mehrheiten ringt auf einen zivilisierter
art und weise ist ein völlig normaler
vorgang genau das tun wir und ich halte
es auch übrigens nicht für aussichtslos
wäre fragt gibt konstanz im großen duell
beim sozial parteitag ich glaube
überhaupt nicht dass es dazu kommt weil
wir nämlich im vorfeld eines sozial
parteitages gespräche führen und schauen
was wir zusammen finden und in den
zielsetzungen unterscheiden wir uns
überhaupt nicht wir unterscheiden uns
und zwar nicht geringe der frage der
finanzierung
darüber muss man reden dann kommt muss
man schauen ob man da zusammenkommt und
wenn man nicht zusammenkommt
alternativen haben sie jetzt noch ein
und entscheidet hast das ist
innerparteilich gelebte demokratie und
ich halte das für eine ganz sportliche
und auch extrem wichtige angelegenheit
und wo man begriff des sportlichen sind
wenn ich den zweiten teil ihrer frage
beantworten ob ich mich freuen würde
wenn höhere kandidiert ich freue mich
grundsätzlich über wettbewerbs weil
wettbewerb einer gesellschaft auch einer
partei immer gut tut und wenn wir auch
einen innerparteilichen wettbewerb um
positionen haben dann finde ich das
erfreulich ob biologen kandidiert oder
nicht da fragen sie jetzt hier den
falschen er sitzt zwei plätze weiter und
er kann sich ja gerne dazu erklären ich
halte es angesichts der von ihm
geäußerten kritik an der zusammensetzung
des bundesvorstandes aus dem juni
jedenfalls für durchaus folgerichtig
wenn die städte und das ist eigentlich
das was ich dazu sagen kann ob er nun
konkret reingeht und wenn ja auf welcher
position auch die fahrer rufen sie auf
das müssen wir fragen und dann muss so
ist das nun mal in einer partei dann
muss der bundesparteitag spricht die 600
delegierten darüber entscheiden
das ergebnis das ist das ergebnis der
gesamten partei dass wir alle
respektieren werden so weit kommen jetzt
muss ich mal einen verehrten
bundesvorsitzenden korrigieren ich habe
mich ja nicht zur personalstruktur des
bundesvorstandes geäußert sondern ich
habe in personalisierte kritik an dem
ein oder anderen was entschieden worden
ist vor dem hintergrund des prinzips der
gleich bahn das noch mal zu ergänzen
ansonsten was die frage nach dem
bundesvorstand angeht bleibe ich bei dem
was ich gerade gesagt habe also mir ist
es vor allen dingen wichtig dass wir als
länder gut repräsentiert werden wir sind
mir ist es wichtig dass das konzept des
solidarischen patriotismus mit personen
und ersetzt wird
wer das am ende sein wird wir haben
viele gute vertreter die das sein
könnten da hinten sitzt einer kino
kubala aus sachsen und andere auch die
sich dafür anbieten
wie gesagt ich bin auch jemand der der
sich nicht so sehr um sich selbst dreht
in der deutschen politik wird meiner
überzeugung nach viel zu viel über
personal gesprochen
es gibt immer nur um ämter und über
machtposition viel zu wenig um inhalte
das bedaure ich sehr also es geht wie
gesagt darum inhalte zu transportieren
und wie gesagt haben wir viele gute
leute
geht's noch mal zu diesem themenkomplex
landolf hladik werte journalisten ich
werde mit diesem thema seit vier oder
fünf jahren die lange das schon wie
lange diese sei schon das dorf
getrocknet getrieben wird und mit
welcher intensität drei tage vor der
landtagswahl dann die ganze geschichte
noch hoch gekocht wurde
ein schelm der böses dabei denkt ja
liebe pressevertreter ich habe schon vor
vier jahren gesagt dass ich nicht unter
pseudonym geschrieben habe und ich war
15 jahre als lehrer tätig hab leider
auch mit mobbing opfern zu tun gehabt
also nicht ich war das mobbingopfer
sondern schüler holz vertrauenslehrer
unterwegs musste mich deswegen auch um
diese mobbing opfer kümmern und habe
mich also intensiv auch mit strukturell
mobbing auseinandergesetzt und das was
sie machen also nicht sie der einzelnen
den ich dann spreche sagen sie als
journalistin wenn sie das thema obwohl
ich mich dazu schon tausend mal gefühlt
geäußert habe immer wieder auf haben
obwohl es keine neuen erkenntnisse gibt
dann ist das mit verlaub systematisches
mobbing
punkt ja weil man vom spiegel erhellte
ich versuche es trotzdem noch mal weil
sie haben gesagt sie wollen sich nicht
dazu äußern werden sie sich noch
nein ich meine nicht zuhören hladik
sondern zu ihrer kandidatur für den
bundesvorstand
da habe ich sie auf einem anderen werfen
bei anderen fällt gerade erwischt
nochmals zu dieser zu diesem
themenkomplex sowie sich verstehe wie
ich sie jetzt versteh wünschen sie sich
eine größere repräsentanz der
ostdeutschen
daraus entnehme ich doch dass sie nicht
antreten werden
und wenn das so ist werden sie
irgendwann das bekannt geben dass sie
nicht antreten werden oder wird das
sozusagen schweigend in dem
bundesparteitag erfolgen sodass am ende
klar ist recke tritt nicht an
also nochmal ja ich möchte dass der
osten besser repräsentiert wird und das
steht uns auch tun nach diesem
wahlerfolg in brandenburg sachsen und
thüringen davon bin ich überzeugt ich
glaube dass als auch im derzeitigen
bundesvorstand so gesehen wird und ja
wir wären natürlich den nächsten tagen
und wochen auch darüber reden und werden
sicherlich auch versuchen eine
kompromisslösung zu kriegen wir wohl
immer das geld was dr gauland zurecht
erwähnt hat der souverän ist der
bundesparteitag der entscheidet
entscheidet letztlich wer gewählt wird
aber natürlich kann man als als
parteiführung man kann nicht nur man hat
auch die pflicht
vielleicht schon im voraus zu klären wer
könnte das denn sein wen könnte man
unterstützen und da wird sicherlich auch
die bemühungen geben um zu lösungen zu
kommen im vorfeld noch mal das muss
nicht ich sein aber das behalte ich mir
vor ob ich keine dir oder nicht
in der politik und das ist auch ein
spruch den doktor gauland des öfteren
zimmer verwendet hat und den habe ich
mir gemerkt in der politik sind drei
tage eine ewigkeit
ja und ich weiß nicht was in vier oder
fünf wochen ist mit verlaub das darf ich
eine nachfrage stellen es gibt es gibt
ja stimmen in ihrer partei wenn auch
anonyme aber
die kann man belegen wenn man es will
die sagen sie würden deswegen
möglicherweise nicht antreten weil ein
eine abstimmung auf einem
bundesparteitag ihn möglicherweise nur
ein durchschnittliches ergebnis bringen
würde und damit wäre sozusagen ein teil
ihres mythos nämlich sozusagen eine
bestimmende kraft in der afg zu sein
dann geklärt
und da sind wir genau wieder in dem
punkt drin den ich von angesprochen habe
immer dieses denken in machtarithmetik
das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht
mit verlaub ich mache in thüringen jetzt
gerade nicht eine zweite fraktion morgen
wir haben in den letzten fünf jahren
eine exzellente parlamentarische arbeit
gemacht
ich habe immer gesagt die veränderung
des landes beginnt über die länder also
über die bundesländer wir müssen
irgendwo als afd in einem bundesland
zeigen dass wir es können dass wir eine
bürgerliche patriotische politik machen
können die dieses land zum guten
verändert und dann wird sich das ganze
fortentwickeln für uns und ich hatte
diesen gang über die länder für eminent
wichtig und ich habe mich in den letzten
fünf jahren da maximal eingesetzt hoffe
ich jedenfalls
das war von erfolg beschieden und
gekrönt das hat man gestern gesehen und
ich werde diesen weg in thüringen weiter
gehen und das ist auch eine aufgabe die
mich voll umfänglich durchaus belastet
und und ausfüllt und lisa ich bin nicht
unbedingt notwendig im bundesvorstand
über das kann konstellation geben wo man
sich dann entscheiden muss doch zu
kandidieren
kollegin wie viele vertreter des ostens
schweben ihnen denn vor in dem neuen
bundesvorstand reichte einer oder müssen
dass mehrere sein und bis wann wollen
sie sich persönlich entscheiden ob sie
antreten
also ich kann ihnen jetzt keine zahlen
nennen also einer ist mir mit sicherheit
zu wenig wir haben drei haben wir
aktuell also von 13 3 von 13
es dürfen ein paar mehr sein aber wie
viel das genau sind das müssen wir jetzt
heute noch nicht bestimmen oder
also nicht entscheiden wollen das kann
ich ihnen jetzt auch noch nicht sagen
tut mir leid dann herr kollege bitte so
rum
christian vollrath von der jungen
freiheit hätte es war heute bei den
anderen parteien öfter die rede von der
staatspolitischen verantwortung die
jetzt alle spüren
spüren sie die weil sich auch und wenn
ja wären sie bereit bestimmte
zugeständnisse an die anderen parteien
zu machen die ja die sie im wahlkampf
hart angegangen sind von den sie hart
angegangen wurden also gibt es da
sozusagen auch ein zuckerbrot was sie zu
bieten haben und das andere richtet sich
vielleicht eher an die
parteivorsitzenden die eben schon
ausgeführt wurde
afg hat herausragende ergebnisse
wahlerfolge jetzt im osten verzeichnet
es gibt den anspruch dass das
entsprechend personell im vorstand
berücksichtigt wird allerdings haben
sämtliche ost bundesländern inklusive
berlin zusammen weniger einwohner
wahlberechtigt
als nrw und welche maßnahmen treffen sie
um zu verhindern dass die afg als
deutsche liga ost wahrgenommen wird ja
staatspolitische verantwortung das ist
etwas damit kann nämlich auch
identifizieren wir haben immer wieder
deutlich gemacht dass wir regieren
wollen wir sind nicht auf vier
positionen abonniert wir haben fünf
jahre parlamentarische erfahrung sammeln
können im thüringer landtag
parlamentarismus erlernt haben ihn uns
angeeignet und sind bereit verantwortung
zu übernehmen
das angebot steht das habe ich gestern
abend auch in alle kameras gesprochen
ist wir sehen eine eine möglichkeit
einer bürgerlichen mehrheit in die oder
die bürgerliche mehrheit ist da in
thüringen die koalitionsmöglichkeiten
wären da koalitionen hängen immer davon
ab was für inhalte letztlich ein
koalitionsvertrag drin stehen und das
ist das was für mich entscheidend dass
wir haben gewisse kernpunkte die sind
nicht verhandelbar
dafür sind wir als afg angetreten dafür
haben wir die afg vor über sechs jahren
gegründet und dann wird man sehen müssen
zu welchen kompromissen man gelangen
kann und ob es kompromiss möglichkeiten
gibt und wie gesagt das angebot
wiederhole ich gerne noch mal ich hab
immer gesagt als juniorpartner kann ich
das nicht empfehlen eine koalition
einzugehen in der konstellation in türen
werden wir der seniorpartner dann
könnten wir es waren kann ich vielleicht
fortsetzen zu dem schönen begriff liga
ost ich mich eine nette idee
nein so ist das so ist das unsinn ich
zunächst einmal ständig voran wir sind
eine partei die sich ja dass es
allgemein bekannt bewusst gegen quote
wendet wenn man keine männer und keine
frauenquote wollen auch keine weste und
keine ost quote machen
das heißt wir haben auch derzeit im
bundesvorstand keinen profit ziehen sich
jetzt noch die landesvorstände oder die
landesverbände beziehen
das ergibt sich es ergibt sich auf den
bundes bundesparteitag ein gewisser
proporz stellt sich üblicherweise ein
wenn die lang großen landesverbände gar
nicht vertreten wären dann murren die
irgendwann werden sich auch gemeinsam
auf jemanden verständigen den sie durch
bringen aber wenn wir einmal schauen was
die aktuelle situation ist dann ist die
situation gar nicht so um proportionen
und dass man sozusagen wenn wir im
moment 33 vertreter der der ostdeutschen
landesverbände im bundesvorstand haben
bei 13 mitgliedern der neuen den neuen
bundesvorstand werden 14 angehören das
ist bei uns von einer von der satzung er
so festgelegt das war ja eine
ausgeschiedenen stefan königer dadurch
sind derzeit nur 13
es wurde nicht nach gewählt die
ostdeutschen landesverbände haben
insgesamt wenn sie mal die stimmenzahlen
anschauen bundesweit betrachtet 27
prozent der stimmen auf sich vereinigt
also fuhr bei guten im viertel und sie
stellen 17 prozent der reeder
da können sie übrigens sehen dass wir im
osten stärker sind als im westen
das heißt wir können jetzt sagen wenn
wir nachts nach weener und gehen dann
wäre sogar noch vielleicht eine oder
zwei weniger wenn wir aber von den
stimmenanteilen ausgenommen das
historien da würde ich ganz genau daran
dass die ost landesverbände sehr stark
abschneiden dann sind wir dabei rund ein
viertel 24 prozent sind etwas über einem
viertel
und dann kommen wir vielleicht statt
statt drei auf vier möglicherweise fünf
meter auseinander das wird nicht während
alexander gerber mich echt ich festlegen
das legen die delegierten fest aber in
dieser größenordnung manager schätzen
sollte wird es liegen und es ist nicht
so maßgeblich ob es jetzt drei vier oder
fünf neuen länder sehe dass er neben mir
uns ist natürlich bewusst dass die
sozialisierung in den ostländern also in
der damaligen ddr eine andere ist als im
westen
und dass es immer auch unterschiedliche
herangehensweisen braucht so dass die
vorstellung einer liga ist natürlich
völlig falsch ist man kann bestimmt
vieles übernehmen im westen aber zum
teil werden im westen andere fragen
gestellt und müssen andere antworten
gegeben werden und diese beweglichkeit
muss bleiben
sie müssen nur auf die italienische lega
gucken
das war ursprünglich sozusagen die
partei von padanien also der poebene das
ist heute eine gesamte italienische
partei und es ist völlig klar dass wir
eine gesamtdeutsche partei bleiben
wollen und müssen und dass wir zwar
erfolgreiche politik aus den ost ländern
übertragen können aber nicht eins zu
eins weil nordrhein-westfalen anders ist
als sachsen oder thüringen
[Musik]
entschuldigung ich würde gerne nochmal
auf die frage des kollegen die sie nicht
beantworten haben ärger eingehen nämlich
sie haben gesagt sie hätten auch fehler
gemacht was für fehler sind denn das
gewesen also ist zum beispiel das
denkmal der shan
ja das habe ich ja schon des öfteren
betont dass die drift in die hose
gegangen ist ich hab das glaube ich als
bierzelt ich habe ich habe eine bierzelt
rede gehalten leider zu diesem thema das
ist kolossal in die hose gegangen ja und
ich habe vielleicht zwei drei reden
gehalten gerade in der anfangsphase wo
wir auch als auf den thüringer auf die
straße gegangen sind weil wir gespürt
haben dass wir im parlament blockiert
werden ja wir haben natürlich nur mal
sagen 200 anträge ins thüringer plenum
in ihr in der jetzt ablaufenden
legislatur eingebracht kein einziger
sinn den ausschuss überwiesen worden
noch nicht mal den ausschuss wurden die
anträge überwiesen hat noch nicht mal
drüber geredet also der
transmissionsriemen des volkswillens
wird von den altparteien blockiert wenn
es um die afg geht und das ist schlecht
deswegen sind wir auf die straße
gegangen und da habe ich mich vielleicht
auch bei den ersten reden etwas im ton
vergriffen ja sie müssen sich das
unternehmen zum ersten mal vor tausenden
von menschen die lautsprecheranlage ist
unter dem sind jetzt sie fangen an sich
selbst nicht mehr zu hören weil die
gegendemonstranten so laut sind dass sie
ihre eigene stimme übertönt alles das
führt dazu dass man manchmal überschlägt
mit der mit der stimme
und dann kommen bilder aus die nicht
schön sind und für die ich mich heute
nicht die nicht schämen wie gesagt das
waren anfängerfehler aber die gemacht
worden sind ja und ich kann die zeit
nicht zurückdrehen die uhr nicht
zurückdrehen
ich habe da auch gelernt aber das ist
unsere nachfrage nur ist der
lebensbejahende afrikanische ausbreitung
typ auch ein fehler
ja das habe ich auch gelernt dass es
gibt dinge die muss man einfach klar
artikulieren und da darf man keinen
interpretationsspielraum lassen
herr kollege bitte hat sich erledigt
[Musik]
und wer hier herr kollege bitte eine
frage von der finanziellen stärke im
juli haben mehr als hundert funktionäre
der afg einen aufruf unterzeichnet in
dem sie an den access sie zur schau
gestellten person person personenkult um
sie abgelehnt haben
und das war nachdem nach ihrer rede auf
dem schiff hause gefreut treffen
wie gehen sie mit dieser internen kritik
in der afg um
ich habe überhaupt gar nichts gegen
interne kritik das ist das was eben
nicht vollzogen worden dass interne
kritik sondern diese kritik ist
öffentlich gemacht worden
das halte ich tatsächlich versteht ist
für die partei dann bitteschön das hat
sich auch nicht und es hat sich auch
erledigt sagte merkel sie haben von
historischen foto von einer historischen
leistung in thüringen gesprochen und
auch über inhalte haben sie gesagt dass
andere viel mehr über andere dinge reden
als über inhalte meine frage ist was ist
eigentlich das oder ihrer meinung nach
hat das geheimnis des erfolgs der alten
thüringen oder auch in anderen
bundesländern
ich habe die frage glaube ich auch schon
mal jetzt schon mal beantwortet also die
das alternative angebot das dass wir
andere inhalte setzen ich schauen sich
an die drei großen politik völlig
benennen sie nochmal euro
rettungspolitik energiewende politik und
einwanderungspolitik dame völlig andere
ansätze als die altparteien wir haben
aber auch in der familienpolitik andere
ansätze und so weiter also das heißt es
gibt vor allen dingen über die
alternativen inhalte die wir anbieten
und die uns zu zu einer die die unter
einer wählbaren alternative machen dass
das wichtig sind das eine das andere ist
vor allen dingen im osten dass die
menschen deswegen haben wir auch die
wände 2.0 kampagnen thüringen gemacht
das die menschen spüren dass es in
diesem land etwas gibt das dass wir die
herrschaft der politischen korrektheit
nennen so eine art meinungs- druck ja
gewisse polit felder sind mit tabus
umstellten sprach verboten und
denkverboten umstellt und wenn wir uns
umfragen ihren ergebnissen jetzt mal
gerade vergegenwärtigen die in den
letzten tagen wochen und monaten gemacht
worden sind beispielsweise dass 41
prozent der menschen im osten sagen sie
können ihre meinung nicht frei äußern
hat zurzeit eine idee oder dass 82
prozent der deutschen sagen laut einer
repräsentativen umfrage dass man besser
gewisse themen in sich nicht öffentlich
traut zu äußern ja dann erkennen wir
dass zwischen dem geschriebenen recht
auf meinungsfreiheit und dem gelebten
recht auf meinungsfreiheit in
deutschland eine große diskrepanz ist
und das macht gerade die menschen im
osten wütend die er vor 30 jahren gerade
für diese grundrechte gekämpft haben und
in einer friedlichen revolution ein
regime hinweggefegt haben dass diese
grundrechte nicht gewehrt hat und das
sind diese diese mentalität relikte dies
noch sehr deutlich ausgeprägt sind im
osten eine erklärung dafür dass jetzt
alle die dort erfolgreich sind weil wir
als partei der meinungsfreiheit auch
klar auftreten
ich versuche die ganze zeit zu verstehen
einsatz frei sie vorhin gesagt haben
die meinungsfreiheit in manchen dingen
ist zu weit oder geht soweit leider habe
ich sie da richtig verstanden
und wenn ihr ergänzen das präzisieren
dass die seelen und was würde dann
geschehen wenn sie die macht hätten mit
denen die mit der meinungsfreiheit etwas
weitergehen
also ich habe vorhin reagiert auf die
geschichte mit dem faschisten und gesagt
ja ich halte es zum beispiel für völlig
verfehlt wie frau künast in einem
gerichtsurteil
sozusagen zurückgewiesen worden ist mit
ihrem anspruch da geht mir die
meinungsfreiheit zu weit
und als herr gefragt worden ist ja
wehren sie sich gegen den faschismus
dann habe ich gesagt ich fürchte das
nützt nichts weil die rechtsprechung in
deutschland so ist das ist keine
auseinandersetzung die jetzt politisch
ist ich glaube dass die rechtsprechung
an bestimmten dingen einhalt gebieten
muss das glaube ich aber schon lange und
das hat nicht aus was mit dem urteil
gegen frau künast zu tun und das habe
ich damit gemeint ich meinte nicht dass
die politik eingreifen soll oder muss
denn diese frage der auslegung ist
letztlich immer eine die vor gerichten
landet und ja ich nehme ein beispiel
ganz offen
der staatsminister im auswärtigen amt
roth hat uns den politischen arm des
rechtsterrorismus genannt da bin ich
sehr dafür gewesen dass wir dagegen
klagen
da hat haben uns juristen gesagt bei der
rechtsprechung die wir haben werden sie
unter umständen verlieren und dann kann
herr roth noch sagen sie sind der
gerichtlich bestätigte rechtsterrorismus
eine solche entwicklung halte ich für
falsch
aber ich muss mich dem der einsicht
derjenigen beugen
die das juristische verfolgen und zudem
ist hier in dem fall dazu gekommen dass
bei der abmahnung nach der abmahnung die
rechtsanwaltskanzlei die das für uns
vertreten hat in übelster weise
angegriffen worden ist
im internet und drohungen sind
ausgestoßen worden gegen
familienmitglieder
das sind alles dinge die überhaupt nicht
gehen und darauf habe ich mich bezogen
mit der meinungsfreiheit und was
gedenken sie zu tun wenn sie an die
regierung kommen und solche dinge zu
korrigieren
ich sagte ihnen ja eben das kann man
kaum vom von vom staat allein von der
regierung aus
korrigieren das ist letztlich eine sache
von rechtsprechung ich glaube dass die
rechtsprechung in der art des zulassens
von persönlichen beschimpfungen
politischen beschimpfungen inzwischen zu
weit geht
das sagen nicht nur still oder sagen
auch andere das können sie nicht
korrigieren
der richter kann natürlich auslegen ob
eine beschimpfung wie sie frau künast
erfahren hat sozusagen noch teil einer
politischen auseinandersetzung ist oder
nicht und ich finde dass die bezeichnung
faschist nicht eine teil einer
politischen auseinandersetzung ist da in
der tat faschismus etwas ist was sich
zurückführen kann auf bestimmte
tatsachen und darauf trifft keine zb auf
antrag dazu
und von daher würde ich mir wünschen
dass man dagegen juristisch vorgehen
könnte aber ich weiß dass das nicht
erfolgreich ist und deshalb machen wir
es nicht aber deshalb billige ich das
nicht gerne auf der brücke zeitung weil
sie eben das thema wenn wir noch mal
bemüht haben erhöhte und schon so lange
jetzt im osten leben fühlen sie sich
eigentlich als ostdeutscher also
identifizieren sie sich als ostdeutscher
mit den ostdeutschen und würden sie auch
wie viele ostdeutsche im nachhinein
sagen der wrestler den osten damals
übervorteilt schlecht behandelt nach der
wende
ich habe mich niemals als westdeutscher
gefühlt
ich bin also immer gesamtdauer ich bin
gesamtdeutsch erzogen worden
also meine großeltern kommen
mütterlicher väterlicherseits aus
ostpreußen diese kultur der alten aus
gebiete ist mir mitgegeben worden und es
war immer klar dass das dass die dass es
keine westdeutsche identität für mich
gibt wenn eine gesamtdeutsche und so
fühle ich mich heute auch als
gesamtdeutscher ich bin deutschland
möchte diese diese trennung nicht in
ostdeutsche und westdeutsche aber
natürlich gibt es noch
mentalitätsunterschiede die schon bei
der beantwortung der der vorherigen
frage zumindest angedeutet habe es gibt
noch die die erfahrung mit dieser
friedlichen revolution die die menschen
prägt und man hat das gefühl dass man
dass man im osten noch ja noch freier
leben kann dass die menschen kritischer
sind auch gegenüber einseitige
medienberichterstattung weil sie auch
gelernt haben im neuen deutschland
zwischen den zeilen zu lesen alles das
ist noch da das noch bestände die da
sind und die die menschen sehr sensibel
machen und das finde ich sehr erfreulich
deswegen gebe ich gern in thüringen und
würde mich freuen wenn die mentalität
des ostens vielleicht irgendwann die
mentalität ganz deutschland sein würde
schneider süddeutsche zeitung
sie haben ja gestern abend beim
wahlabend wohl auch davon gesprochen
dass sie für die nächsten wahl noch
größere ziele hätten aber sie sprachen
von einer absoluten mehrheit die sie als
ziel haben
wie kann man sich denn vorstellen wie
eine regierung aus einer regierung als
erstes umsetzen sollte die von ihnen
geführt würde
sie wird können sie vielleicht in zwei
drei sätzen sagen und das zweite
ergaunern
wann rechnen sie das erste mal für die
afg mit einer regierungsbeteiligung
ich habe diese 51 prozent habe ich
folgendermaßen kontextualisiert dass ich
gesagt habe mit blick auf die cdu wenn
die cdu wirklich was mit den linken
macht dann wird sie den weg der
italienischen christdemokratie gehen das
ist der weg in die politische
bedeutungslosigkeit
und das würde bedeuten dass wir gerade
im bereich der das des bürgerlichen
wähler klientel sin allein
alleinstellung hätten und dann könnten
tatsächlich auch im osten
und wir haben ja in thüringen auch schon
regierung mit absoluter cdu-mehrheit gab
also strukturell ist es möglich könnten
wir da das erbe antreten das hatte ich
gar nicht mehr so unrealistisch je
nachdem wie sich das land weiter
entwickelt und zu ihrer zweiten frage
wir haben ja nur ein 100 seitiges
landtagswahlprogramm niedergeschrieben
dass jedermann einsehen kann da sind
unsere ziele ja abgedruckt in 19
kapiteln haben wir uns da aus geführt
und haben ja viele
handlungsmöglichkeiten offen gelegt
beispielsweise ein abschiebe initiative
wird 2020 würden wir starten wir wollen
eine industrialisierung und
infrastruktur offensive machen wir
wollen einen thüringen fonds auflegen
eine auffang für junge unternehmer die
vielleicht beim ersten mal gescheitert
sind wir mit ihrer unternehmung weil wir
ein lebendiges unternehmertum in türen
fördern möchten wir wollen eine familie
offensiver machen um das problem
demografischer wandel anzupacken auch
ein politikfeld das von den altparteien
seit jahrzehnten sträflich
vernachlässigt wird es gibt viel zu tun
und wir haben über all unsere
alternativen möglichkeiten und ideen und
die wollen wir gerne umsetzen heißt
leider ich bin kein visionär und sollte
es aber realität werden dass die cdu mit
der linkspartei eine koalition bildet
könnte das sehr viel schneller eintreten
weil ich annehme dass das was herr
lindemann heute ausgedrückt hat viele in
der cdu denken dass die cdu tatsächlich
mit der ehemaligen mountain oder partei
koaliert das glaube ich nehmen die
mitglieder der cdu vor allem im westen
über
und von daher kann ich ihnen keinen
zeitpunkt nennen aber ich glaube das
würde dann schneller gehen als ich es
mir bis jetzt vorgestellt habe die
letzte frage noch mal anknüpfend an die
freunde sondern euch kurz vorstellen dpd
entschuldigung noch manche sind an die
frage von herrn klocke vor allen dingen
nach ihrer eigenen sie sagen das amt
deutschen sozialisation ist sie sind in
den wahlkampf gezogen mit dem slogan
wende 2 0 das war auch in anderen
ostdeutschen bundesländern bei der hfg
der fall dennoch haben sie von den
ereignissen auf dieser seite der mauer
damals nicht viel mitbekommen
wie erklären sie sich denn wenn sie auf
das erbe der friedlichen revolution
verweisen dass es nicht die vorkämpfer
von damals waren die in der ersten reihe
der afg dabei stehen wenn sie sagen wir
sind eigentlich die das aber der
friedlichen revolution von 89
verteidigen und empfinden sie es selbst
als makel dass die vorsitzenden wie sie
das ist auch eine frage an herrn bauland
und herren und herren keilwitz in
brandenburg eben nicht ostdeutsche sind
nein das ist kein makel warum sollte das
sein marke sein
ich kann ihn für thüringen sagen dass
wir als wir den landesverband führen
aufgebaut haben anfang 2013
dass wir damals sehr viele mitstreiter
hatten die diese friedliche revolution
mitgestaltet haben also wirklich an
vorderster front mitgekämpft haben für
die freiheit gekämpft haben ihr leben
riskiert haben letztlich wusste man
nicht wie das ganze ausgehen würde das
heißt der geist der afg thüringen ist
tatsächlich auch zu einem großen teil
von diesen friedlichen revolutionären
geprägt und ich bin stolz darauf dass
ich diesen landesverband führen kann und
darf und noch mal ich habe und als die
wende kam war ich 18 jahre alt
17 jahre 17 jahre alt macht
das war das war für mich schon sehr
bewusst ich habe ja vorher mit der
deutschen teilung beschäftigt ich kann
mich noch erinnern dass ich mit 14
jahren die junge union eingetreten dass
ich in meinen aufnahmeantrag als wir
ankreuzen mussten welche politikfelder
mich besonders interessieren
deutschlandpolitik angekreuzt hatte also
dass das geteilte deutschland war für
mich etwas das zu überwinden war
und ich habe mich damit sehr intensiv
beschäftigen als die friedliche
revolution losging habe ich mitgefiebert
und habe alle fernseh sendung verfolgt
ich kann mich noch genau daran erinnern
wie stark sich diese ereignisse bewegt
haben und von daher wie gesagt war ich
mit dem herzen immer dabei auch wenn ich
nicht persönlich eingreifen konnte ich
habe mein abitur in der friedrich engels
oberschule in karl marx stadt gemacht
also wenn sie mich schon fragen dann bin
ich sowohl ausdauer wie westdeutsche ja
was mich an lange habe ich meine ganz
spezifischen erfahrung mit der mauer
gemacht den 80er jahren
die werde ich aber jetzt hier nicht
ausbreiten weil das teil meines meines
privatlebens ist das vielleicht auch
interessant ist mit dem ich sie auch
nicht behelligen möchte ich betrachte
mich als deutschland nicht als
ostdeutscher noch als westdeutscher ich
hab das einfach ich hab's satt geld
sitzt drei jahre her und diese ständigen
die polarisierung die der stadt finden
es ist meine sache nicht ich habe den
den osten durch meine politische
tätigkeit noch viel mehr kennengelernt
und ich muss sagen auch ins herz
geschlossen
diese wahlkämpfe im osten die machen
immer richtig spaß und ich fühle mich da
so pudelwohl wie im westen des landes
haben nur große sorge dass wir uns alle
hier in einigen jahren nicht mehr
wohlfühlen werden deswegen mache ich
politik wenn ich da für dich noch eine
nachfrage gerne stellen
ärger als die folgen von gesamtdeutscher
sozialisation gesprochen haben sie haben
gesagt gesamtdeutsche sozialisation und
haben dann auf ihre großmutter in
ostpreußen verwiesen bevor es wieder zu
missverständnissen kommen könnten sie
das einfach noch mal klarstellen wie sie
das gemeint haben also die frage
verstehe ich jetzt nicht ganz gut
verlauf die sprachen von einer
gesamtdeutschen soziale entschuldigung
wenn ich das habe ich einen in der
beantwortung einer frage gerade eben
ausgeführt dass das wir immer
mitgefiebert haben mit den ereignissen
auf der anderen seite des eisernen
vorhangs 30 liegt aber noch ein bisschen
weiter ist ich sage ja das habe ich das
habe ich erklärt dass das meine dass
meine vorfahren also mütterlichen
väterlicherseits aus ostpreußen kommen
und dass gewisse kultur bestände dann
auch weiter getragen worden sind von der
großelterngeneration in die eltern
generation nämlich damit auch noch
kontakt gekommen bin und wenn sie mal
ein buch lesen dafür ich sogar zu aus
würde ich empfehlen jetzt sage ich danke
für diesen montag intensive nachwahl zur
landtagswahl in thüringen